Через встановлення арок Керченського мосту
Росія перекриє найглибшу частину керченської протоки
у певні дні серпня і вересня  для суден
що прямують в українські порти
Українські блоґери забили на сполох
Мовляв, після встановлення арок під ними
зможуть пройти лише невеликі кораблі
а це паралізує діяльність українських морських портів в Азовському морі
На сайті Керченського мосту
з Росії до окупованого Криму зазначено
проектна висота судоходної арки - 35 метрів
довжина – 227
Проектувальники мосту обіцяють
що глибина фарватеру під ним сягатиме 9,3 метрів
Це дозволятиме проходити суднам з осадкою 8 метрів
За даними сайту Маріупольського порту
він здатен приймати судна з максимальною осадкою 8 метрів
Якщо подивитися на Traffic Marine
онлайн-карту руху кораблів
31 липня у порту Маріуполя стояло сім вантажних суден
У найбільшого з них осадка - 8 метрів
Однак Маріупольський порт
також приймає судна типу "Панамакс"
які мають осадку 14 метрів
Щоб ці судна могли зайти в маріупольський порт
їх завантажують не повністю
Тоді вони не перевищували допустиму глибину осадки
Висота ж таких кораблів сягає 63 метрів
Тож після завершення будівництва
міст заблокує рух кораблів типу "Панамакс"
в українські порти Азовського моря
Окрім цього, міст, побудований всупереч нормам міжнародного права
несе і інші загрози для вантажоперевезень
В зимовий період Азовське море замерзає
і вантажне судоплавство у найглибшій частині керченської протоки
Керч-Єнікальському каналі - можливе лише після прокладання маршруту криголамом
На російських ресурсах йдеться про те
що взимку у проливі дрейфує крига і міст буде захищений від її впливу
Однак нічого не йдеться про те, що саме опори мосту
і будуть затримувати великий масив криги
Накопичення криги може заблокувати прохід кораблів під мостом
На сайті Керченського мосту також йдеться про
проведення навколо будівництва антитерористичних навчань
Не виключено, що у будь-який момент після побудови мосту
російська сторона, посилаючись на терористичну загрозу
може перекрити арку, під якою проходять кораблі
Росія в порушення договору з Україною від 2003 року
про співробітництво у використанні Азовського моря
і Керченської протоки на час будівництва мосту визначила акваторії
в яких заборонено судноплавство
Там ходять лише російські військові кораблі
Посилення присутності російського флоту
у районі Керченського мосту може завадити морській комерції
Міжнародні перевізники намагаються уникати
мілітаризованих акваторій і місць потенційного конфлікту
Виходячи з наведених фактів можна зробити висновок
Керченський міст як інженерна споруда перекриє прохід суден
типу "Панамакс" до українських портів в Азовському морі
Балкери з осадкою до 8 метрів зможуть проходити
Разом з тим, російський односторонній військовий контроль
над входом у судоходний Керч-Єнікальський канал дозволяє Москві
в будь-який момент заблокувати доступ суден до українських портів в Азовському морі.
Також конструкція мосту може ускладнити
або й унеможливити прохід всіх типів суден в зимовий період